sí
ok la animación directa funciona pero
algunas veces es difícil saber hacia
dónde vamos
muchas veces lo que ayuda es empezar
trabajando con algo que conocemos como
poses clave para una pelota que rebota
esas serían cuando se encuentra en su
punto más alto y otra donde toque el
piso empecé dibujando el cuadro uno
hasta arriba y ahora dibujar el cuadro 9
en el piso
ahora ya podemos dibujar los cuadros
intermedios usando estas poses claves
como guía
dibujar el cuadro 5 a la mitad a este
llamaremos pose intermedia y ahora puedo
seguir agregando más cuadros
subdividiendo el espacio a veces es muy
útil usar una guía para poder
identificar todos los números
muy bien ahora que terminamos los
dibujos vamos a reproducirlos de hecho
podemos hacer una trampa levantando los
dibujos salir hacia atrás
la pelota se mueve pero no se ve muy
real muchas veces antes de que empieces
ayuda mucho grabar un vídeo como
referencia si tienes una idea de lo que
haces recuerden la pelota acelera
conforme cae al piso
nuestro cuadro 5 está a la mitad en el
tiempo de animación pero la pelota no
está esa distancia del piso en ese
momento
así que mejor voy a dibujar un nuevo
cuadro 5 que tenga más relación con la
primera pose tal vez lo dibujaré a una
tercera parte los animadores han
desarrollado un lenguaje visual usando
estas líneas temporales para mostrar
cómo espaciar los dibujos entre las
poses clave recuerden que el cuadro 5 se
encuentra a un tercio de la distancia
entre el 1 y el 9 y voy a dibujar el
cuadro 3 a un tercio de distancia entre
1 y 5 y así consecutivamente estos
cuadros nos ayudan a colocar los dibujos
intermedios
cuando reproducimos esto la pelota
acelera al caer al piso
ahora veamos como usamos la misma
técnica para una animación pose a pose
en la computadora
empezaremos colocando la pelota en el
aire en el cuadro como antes y después
nos brincamos al cuadro 9 para poner la
pelota en el piso
debajo de la imagen la computadora nos
muestra esta gráfica que es como la
línea temporal en dos dimensiones y nos
muestra como la computadora calculará
los cuadros intermedios
el eje horizontal es el tiempo y el eje
vertical indica que tan arriba está la
pelota checa esto si proyectamos las
intersecciones de cada cuadro en el eje
vertical terminamos exactamente con la
misma línea temporal que usan los
animadores en 2d
puedes ver que para la caída la
computadora conecta las poses con una
línea recta en la gráfica a esto se le
llama interpolación lineal y se obtiene
aún cuando espaciados las poses
cuando reproducimos de nuevo la pelota
se mueve a una velocidad constante
ahora inténtalo tú mismo ve si puedes
lograr una animación convincente de una
pelota que rebota usando interpolación
lineal y como sugerencia puedes agregar
cuadros intermedios extras para obtener
el espaciamiento que requieras